la période de fêtes c'est le moment où
l'action bénévole et la plus importante
de l'année pour beaucoup beaucoup
d'organismes
sauf que cette année ils manquent de
bras c'est peut-être une façon de mettre
un peu de magie différente cette année
on va les aider les autres justement
michel alexandre cochon était avec nous
directeur général de la fédération des
centres d'action bénévole du québec et
de jeu bénévoles point ces acquis et un
site de jumelage entre bénévoles et
organismes mais ce cochon bonjour
bonjour merci d'éclat en pleine journée
internationale du bénévolat en plus
est-ce que la pandémie ça met beaucoup
de bâtons dans les roues le présentement
vous manqué beaucoup de bénévoles mais
c'est sûr que la pandémie le change la
donne jusqu'à surtout dans les mesures
qui avaient bénévoles et les organismes
pour qu'anvers service mais en terme de
recrutement de bénévoles
l'enjeu est un peu à valady maintenant
c'est sûr qu'il ya des bénévoles qui ont
dû quitter le marché ce bénévole heures
dont ses amis aux publications sur les
ailes les organismes actuels sur les 100
actions bénévoles
mais il ya la personne âgée bénévoles
comme vous l'avez dit il qui permet aux
organismes instruire les offres sur les
c est ainsi que les bénévoles peuvent
aller qui directement sur l'offre oif
que rare tant pour les organismes qui en
ont besoin
mais quand vous me dites il ya des gens
qui ont quitté le marché du bénévolat
on pense que c'est aux personnes un peu
plus âgés qui ont dû se mettre un peu à
l'abri pour se protéger du virus
effectivement donc accumulé mallowan
masque déjà de 65 le sens tu quittais
bénévolat cela étant dit aujourd'hui
dans le 5 décembre
c'est jean-luc sont à santé peuvent
venir le faire du bénévolat dans ce sens
assez en forme ronde et il peut le faire
qu'une chose qu'on voit spécifié
vraiment c'est qu'ils restent potable et
saint maixent bénévoles voilà reprenait
bénévoles est remplacé sur certaines
autres services que certains que tout
est respecté selon les normes rassemblés
dans ce bain de voix et sans extras
bénévoles de respecter ces
ces consulats bon cette année on le sait
le ya pas de rassemblement pour les
fêtes
mais beaucoup de besoins quand même
parce qu'il ya des familles qui ne
pourront pas nécessairement facilement
le se faire de réveillon avec leurs
enfants à la maison donc les besoins
sont au grand ou sont justement les
besoins les plus importants en termes de
bénévolat présentement alors faites sur
ce pur si je venais validement sont
vraiment se rediriger vers tout ce qui
épate roulant donc la livraison de repas
à domicile pour les gens qui sont plus
isolés plus vulnérables il ya une limite
pas eu du tout parce qu'on retrouve sur
le site général mais je dirais que les
deux cas harsha s'est passé deux servis
sur ses deux activités bénévoles
ok et puis avec l'annulation des
rassemblements est ce que vous croyez
que des gens qui n'auront plus à se
mettre en quarantaine avant noël ce qui
était prévu dans le fameux contrat moral
avec le gouvernement le go et est ce que
ça va vous permettre à votre avis
d'avoir plus de gens disponibles on le
souhaite
nous souhaitons lui reste reste à voir
ce que sa voix est ce que ça va donner
il faut savoir que l'application
bénévoles il faut l'essayer une fois
c'est juste de rentrer dans la roue du
bénévolat une seule fois on est en
allégeant leur action bénévole et le
métier nous qui les intéressent en face
on en convient donc en terminant comment
ça fonctionne on va sur gée bénévoles
point c1
et puis à ce moment là on va trouver
toutes sortes d'offres comme des offres
d'emploi finalement et ça commence
vraiment c'est de jumelage pour le
bénévole ya deux façons de s'inscrire il
peut s'inscrire dans une pente des
bénévoles
compte tenu des ressources humaines et
au respect du quota sont plus limités ça
a été comme le plus de travail pourquoi
de recherche et tout et tout donc on
demande où on incite les bénévoles ou
les cartables et des voix vraiment
s'inscrire sur 8,9 dont quatre vols sur
le site de sony
peu importe la région qui vont choisir
le vraiment des offres sont régionaux
ici des cinq fils
sur cette offre là là pour donner
directement la gestion pour les organes
communautaires qui ont c'est là son
roman d'une version 6 lancée voilà c'est
ça ça peut donner un bon coup de main et
ça peut apporter une magie différente
cette année pour passer les fêtes de les
aider dans divers organismes
ce cochon merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous mais ce coup j'en profite pour
souhaiter une très belle merci ce qu'ils
ont dit oui c'est très important
effectivement merci merci bonne journée